[Music]
in a freak accident news submitted by I
know caught a a woman lost her voice for
for 12 years after accidentally
swallowing a coin which is why my mom
always told me to spit 12 years what did
you swallow look she got it back you
never saw him a coin no it was lodged
there for 12 years 12 years it was
lodged yes where is this taking place
did she knows she did not know she
didn't look that's planes Istanbul what
so random in Istanbul
not even close I'm thinking about funny
shape coins I'm thinking maybe Turkish
coins are pretty funny shape why what do
they look like yeah look ridiculous
maybe it's an octagon the outside of the
square in the middle what's that one
would I have the holes in the middle
there's a Japanese coin that's a I think
it's five yen there's a hole in the
middle that's cool less less waste do
you know I'm saying yes so her name is
Marie when she was 13 years old back in
1972 in Turkey in Australia clothes so
cool now it's I'm picturing a koala coin
I'm sure they have Australian I don't
know under money yeah it's a big coin
and then you put a little coin in the
front okay it's a 10 cent that can hold
a 5 cent to make 15 cents ok so what
ended up happening she doesn't know it's
a complete mystery how this coin ended
up in her throat mmm I've heard that
story before
yeah it's a real trip though because mr.
to the doctor that coin was from now
what she looks like
I'll show you sorry I always cheat okay
so the coin that she had in her throat
for 12 years it was a 1959 Australian 3
pen pen I'm glad I know the year which
had not the years important it gives
context because it had been out of
circulation for years by the time she
put a better it's valuable then it's
like a collector's jacket that was the
only way she could steal it at the age
of 13 [ __ ] yeah you didn't steal that 13
I stole hell of [ __ ] yeah I stole a
helical ection so she swallowed up being
like I'm gonna [ __ ] this out later cuz
it's a collector's item and then
joke's on her I remember finding the
quarter like the drummer boy quarters
and I'm like I was like what there's a
different quarter and I'll take all my
mom's coins and open it all out to see
if I could find any more that map with
all the states and the poor guy that
[ __ ] on [ __ ] CTV or whatever it's
called the place late at night
oh the Home Shopping Network or whatever
HSN they cleaned it up but United States
with the law holding because there's
funny pennies to get all that wheat
pennies the whip any different you guys
ever swallow those gold flakes what yep
balls lick yes I'm that Goldschlager
stuff what about it you ever do it no
swallowing metals oh okay wait let me
finish telling you her thing okay she
ended up going to the doctor because all
of a sudden she lost the ability to
speak and thought that she just had a
really bad case of bronchitis and then
she ended up recovering from the illness
but she still couldn't utter a sound no
one ever was like we should x-ray so
yeah she did get x-rays and what's it
facing this one flat sides like this
last so unlock could ensue so they
didn't know what the hell was wrong with
her so she yeah you can service you
ended up going she's trying to steal
transduce does mom know when you do
x-rays of the chest they do it you have
to do this this this cuz they learned we
don't know how they do it oh [ __ ] that
was back in 1972 yeah in Australia yeah
so then she ended up just living her
life as a mute had to learn her but she
could always poke if she got that out if
she got that out but she didn't know
that it was there like should she ever
throw up so this is what happened she
got drunk one day which is 21 so one day
while she was at work in 1984 when she
was 25 years old she just started
coughing out of nowhere like she just
had this crazy coffee tack oh my god she
ended up going to the bathroom and she
started coughing up blood and that's
when she panicked she went to the
hospital in an ambulance and then that's
when doctors looked in her throat and
then the first time a lump covered in
blood and mucus and then after rinsing
it they found out it was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] musician either
oh my god if you reverse that it looks
like you're eating it dick yeah on the
dick just what you were doing what does
she actually have it on your necklace
huh I would throw it away
luckily I got rid of it food or Nothing
pushed it down yeah food or nothing I
know please hear your voice for the
first time in ten years the old English
oh where she wakes up good morning see
because that's the last time she not
speak oh my she's a business 12 years a
long time for language yeah like someone
that steals it's like a picture those
teeth those are robbing teeth that girl
was trying to be a fountain how do you
not remember like that's some stupid
[ __ ] at 13 years old
yeah brain man so did she wake up with
the coin swallow or dinner [ __ ] two
chefs siblings wait she's creeping with
her mouth open her brother [ __ ]
throws a coin in there copy that picture
to the one we just saw I was twelve
years no damn she did not age well I was
like that looks like 40 years kind of
that's the other thing she got the coin
out in 1984 in 84 people like to give a
[ __ ] and say we do old articles guess
what [ __ ] comes from 1984 you
guys reason why we're talking about it
35 years later the book okay [ __ ]
coin boy ma'am [ __ ] her book is called
voiceless by surviving swallowing a coin
her traumatic experience of losing her
attic so all these mutes are [ __ ]
like shut the [ __ ] up I think it's
pretty traumatic just like this I think
it's pretty traumatic you lose your
voice for 12 years talking about dude
every time I lose my boys and I have
with
I am so frustrated but I feel like if
it's getting back it's traumatic if you
lose it and it's gone forever you learn
to live with this part of your life well
she obviously had to learn to live with
it Photography people get paralyzed like
it's probably traumatic gonna be get it
is trying to get me go probably sorry
I'm not trying to minimize the drama and
then it becomes your life and your brain
has to change like if I want to live a
full life
so if you went blind you wouldn't want
the site to come back no of course I
would but if it never did I'd like this
in my life I don't know any different
and then you tour the world talking
about helped me become a motivational
speaker yep and then you write out do
you write a book yep but you can no
she's a scammer no no when you go back
from it I don't know but yeah for 12
years that being able to speak and then
all of a sudden just pop out this coin
in it long time we read this article we
know what happens
what can you may help me with a whole
book out of this it was a 12 year
journey because of not being maybe she
was like all I could have talked to
these guys I wanted to talk yeah maybe
like certain experience I missed out so
much but stay positive yeah we went to
the blind opaque yeah and you're in the
dark and they're telling you they're
blind story that's like me being like
okay I got it you're blind
wow you're so serious what actually
makes sense that was a bit though I'm
gonna talk about the blind something oh
[ __ ] yeah but bird box you'd be biting
those [ __ ] birds for sure I still
haven't watched you're fine but you know
what schools I think they shot it in
like Monrovia mass Edina yeah so you'll
see some areas like oh no we have to
think about just Sandra Bullock chillin
passive yeah two weeks out of that
what's the funny grew up there how did
she NASA Deena yeah she grew up in those
see for some reason she hasn't aged at
all no she hasn't she was better now I
think yeah she did yeah it's pretty good
but anyway have you guys had any freak
accidents happen to you well I fell
asleep on my hand one time and I let
that actually have my hand like this for
six months no I swear it's the type of
palsy it's called something palsy but
but yeah basically I'll be palsy
we put Bobbsey palsy I fell asleep on it
and killed the nerves in my wrist so my
wrist was blocked like this you [ __ ]
jerk is jerking off yeah you can't go
with the left hand no problem no good
that feels like someone else's hand
that's true that's all nice what what
was crazy about it is I'm in there with
guys who like lost their arms and like
Afghanistan and [ __ ] and like they're
trying to like Heather legs blown off a
chip but war heroes yeah we're heroes
and all you sit here you're sitting like
a pterodactyl pit comes back stories
real nice my sister
I am I hope feeling because cuz I
flipped my family thought I was torn
because I was I was doing at roll back
right 2006 I was 2 years out of high
school and so I was showing my family I
was like slapping my hand on cabinets
and [ __ ] like you're full of [ __ ] yeah
right so I turned on the hot water so it
was so hot that steam is coming out I
put my hand you wouldn't feel it I
should have stabbed it you just thanks
for the notes you know dude you really
couldn't feel you can feel anything no
didn't feel [ __ ] you guys sound crazy
that now that you say that I wasn't
gonna tell this story but since we're
talking about dumb [ __ ] my freak
accident was I had jaw surgery and the
guy cut my nerve and I have no feeling
in my chin like poke my children yeah
you can't feel it
uh-uh what is this where do you start
feeling it it kind of like dissolves oh
really all right yeah can you feel here
yeah here I can feel well it goes away
right here I didn't mess with your
speech oh [ __ ] yeah people on the
internet comment all the time like it's
really cool it's like no I have a
[ __ ] disability
I use up in greeting was a [ __ ] to get
them in my apartment so I was carrying a
bunch of plastic grocery bags I had like
seven of them or some [ __ ]
and I walked like four blocks and I
couldn't feel the tips of my fingers for
like three weeks circulation I think I
got weak nerves you probably were
holding like 20 bags
is there anything strong about me yeah I
mean you asked my wife I think she would
tell you I'm a powerful [ __ ] after
probably no I can't know if my dick gets
too hard yeah then I can't get hard [ __ ]
stories
[Music]
[Music]